it's interesting how we go from a movie
called lilo and stitch to its sequel
stitch to its other sequel called lilo
and stitch to thrown away I kind of
understand it seeing how stitch was
obviously a pilot to a TV series like
Tarzan and Jing was a pilot to a TV
series but then they come out with
Tarzan - and lilo and Stitch - which
seem more like actual sequels it's also
interesting that these sequels seem to
fall into the slew of smaller stories
they definitely connect to the first one
but they're not as big or grand and well
with the exception of Mulan - there's
surprisingly kind of welcomed I really
enjoyed Tarzan - I thought a lot of
great effort was put into it and here
that's what's not too bad either for the
most part we'll get to the bad stuff -
in this movie stitch has a glitch he
starts acting all evil and attacking
people and doing all sorts of terrible
things but it comes and goes
eventually it's discovered that this
came from a glitch that happened years
ago and the Russian alien is trying to
figure out how to stop it
well that's going on lilo has this big
hula competition that she really wants
to win especially seeing how her mother
won eight years ago and the rest of the
story focuses less on alien encounters
and explosions and ray guns and more on
them just trying to figure out what to
do for their hula contest and keeping
stitch under control like I said a much
smaller movie but for what it is it's
actually alright in the first film I
thought the sisters really stole the
show and in the second film I thought
the aliens really stole the show and
here it seems perfectly balanced both
lilo and stitch are a ton of fun to
watch they're just adorable
I love how she's written like a real
little kid and that sort of spreads to
stitch as well the side characters
though nobody really knew I'll a fun to
watch as well does that make it as good
as the first well there are a couple
problems there's one or two awkward
moments that just come across as odd for
example the Russian alien knows that
stitch has a glitch and he's trying to
put together this device but he keeps it
a secret for some reason why would he do
that
shouldn't everybody know that this thing
can explode at any moment and he can
attack people and seriously hurt them or
even kill them why is he keeping it a
secret he's sneaking around trying to
get household items to build this device
to save him but why does he just tell
people I'll tell you why cuz you have to
have a scene where lilo thing stitch is
really bad and stitch does feel bad
this misunderstanding and it's stupid
it's so friggin stupid
there's also minor things like the
romance between naughty and the
boyfriend is kind of bland once again I
get thing never really got this right
sometimes there's a read from an actor
that clearly needed to be done again and
even the watercolor backgrounds are a
little too obvious this time I don't
know I remember the first family was
blended a little better but here it just
looks super flat and I know that's kind
of the idea of watercolor but I don't
know it doesn't blend as well here
oh and without giving too much away
there is a huge cop-out ending there's a
really emotional moment the acting is
great the animation is great but then
suddenly is just retcon and they never
explain why it's just kind of magic I
guess or is it magic is it science I
don't know it just comes out of nowhere
and they openly admit they don't know
why it happened stuff like this that
could so easily be fixed is what keeps
it from being as good as the original
but still I'd be lying if I said I
didn't enjoy a lot of it again as
smaller stories go most of the same
actors are back with the exception of
lilo who this time is replaced by Dakota
Fanning and by God she does a great job
impersonating her not just the voice but
the heart the comedy the emotion she
really gets it I don't know if they
switched her out because they wanted to
pick her celebrity or if the original
actresses voice was changing but she
does a great job you barely even noticed
the difference so even though it's a
sequel that doesn't really add much and
yeah probably doesn't need to exist I
still have a soft spot for lilo and
Stitch and if you do too you'll probably
enjoy this grab your hover ship and
check it out
you